so why has the road to brakes it becomes
so chaotic think back to the 8th of June
2017 general election day the day mrs.
may expect you to get a majority of more
than a hundred seats which would have
given her the status and numbers to get
her a sort of makes it deal through the
House of Commons instead
she ended up with a hung parliament
dependent on a disgraceful deal she'd
done with the DUP from that day onwards
she was powerless her authority had
disappeared and she had virtually no
chance of getting any sort of back
breaks it deal through the Parliament
from that day on it was only a matter of
time before we had the sort of shambles
we've seen in the past few days her
position got worse on Wednesday when she
promised not to lead the toys into the
next election which has entrenched her
position of being in office but not in
power
mrs. Mae should have resigned last June
we are where we are because of that
fateful election to broaden it out we
are where we are because of that
election yeah you're probably right
but we're there because if you ask me to
identify where the problems are I would
suggest they were two events both of
which actually fell on her predecessors
watch David Cameron with his going in
February the year of the referendum and
in fact I think we can remind ourselves
of what he said and let's hear what the
prime minister said and then I'll tell
you why I think that was slip number one
I've negotiated a deal to give the
United Kingdom special status inside the
European Union I will fly back to London
tonight and update the cabinet at 10
a.m. tomorrow morning this deal has
delivered on the commitments I made at
the beginning of this renegotiation
process I believe that this is enough
for me to recommend that the United
Kingdom remain in the European Union
having the best of both worlds so that
was David Cameron after those
negotiations February 2016 and it has
been reported that people who wear
sweaters a bit like Majid all the
European a European said is this going
to be an
to which mr. cammeron replied yes I will
get this through slip number one slip
number two and I've said this before on
the show and I'll keep it really brief
something as momentous as this had to
have a clearer percentage it had to be
probably fifty five plays forty five at
the least or probably a new run
businesses sixty forty because it is
such a quantum leap unless I get a 60 40
or maybe 50 we stay with the status quo
those are the slips 19 you made yeah
yeah but if she had got a majority of
hundred oh yes she could probably she
had have had the authority I'm an
authority went that day didn't it what
you want you you go into an election
with a big lead and you come out with a
minority government yeah you're in real
trouble well I agree with everything
you're saying but I think we need to go
back further because the real issue even
if we had imagined some dream leader
scenario right now brexit was
fundamentally based on a set of
undeliverable promises that was never
going to placate everybody so my moment
is this just have a look at what Michael
Gove said it should be win-win for us
and it will be if we vote to leave and
we can maintain free trade stop sending
money and also have control of our
borders it was this ideal that we will
be in the best case scenario
there will be no losses and it was
disingenuous and people up in our
country honest reasonable people voted
thinking that it was going to make us
better off have more control and more
money and it wasn't true and it's
inevitable that whoever was running the
show was going to come up against
reality reality was going to hit and I
can't leave that without showing you
this lemon this bathroom this is the
thing you know people who don't know
about the backstop and don't understand
customs union and tariffs they
understand 350 million pounds a week
from the NHS that leads to people they
thought that they were voting for that
money in their local hospital
that's not deliverable and it's not just
because Theresa made those systems as it
is I just have to start he stands by the
figures let's not forget resumes
promising to provide those funds if we
vote for her her deal but no I think
again going before the point in time
that you've identified grid I think
the big mistake was for the Prime
Minister her predecessor David Cameron
to bargain the future constitutional
relationship this country has with the
European Union to settle an internal
civil war an internal dispute within his
political party he should not have
called the referendum which has only got
worse
look why the popular do you keep them
what well that may well be the party
resort that wraps the party needed to
split you Kip was popular but it was you
know it was chipping away certain votes
from certain sectors let's have a look
at what David Cameron said at that time
Democratic consent for the EU in Britain
is now wafer-thin some people say that
pointing this out is irresponsible but
it creates uncertainty for business and
puts a question mark over Britain's
place in the European Union but the
question mark is already there ignoring
it is not going to make it go away that
is why I am in favor of having a
referendum you just love that camera
angle well I think actually it was
already time for the political parties
to reform by then because their
alignment especially within the
Conservatives something obviously labour
was then coming after that but it was
already that the cracks were beginning
to appear at the seams I'll tell you
even on the labor side I made a
conscious decision not to join the
labour party when Edie millet when Ed
Miliband became leader because I felt
that was too left-wing for me now I have
a nostalgia nostalgia looking back at
those days my god I'd be happy you know
bill about Labour Party compared to what
probably then brought along that after
after that but the cracks were already
there I think actually the political
realignment needed to occur rather than
holding a countenance to ditch and still
needs to it yeah yes when you're saying
like what went wrong I would have gone
back years when we were talking about
proportional representation and we voted
against having that and I think for me
where this all kind of went wrong was
when you had you kept your point I think
it got something like 4 million votes
and it ended up with 1c in Parliament
and by default as well so I think then
you ended up with so many people that
was so unrepresented in Parliament and
still filled by the way on represented
in Parliament so you've got this massive
swell of people that
so unrepresented disengaged frustrated
so you had to give the referendum to
appease those people so I think if we'd
have had proportional proportional
representation and you keep were more
strongly represented I think we could
have avoided the situation the first
place point one and point two once we
had the referendum I think where we were
fully went wrong was with zero
preparation at all of considering the
fact that we might have gone for brexit
and I think that was so wrong you mean
No Deal
yes sorry yeah I think it was no no no
it's too averted brexit so I think at
the point of referendum there was zero
consideration that actually if we brexit
what would that look like because people
didn't think it would happen and they're
in fast-forward again my final point is
for no deal there's never been any
serious concert them consideration No
Deal so what you have now is people
going oh we can't crash out with No Deal
well actually if you'd have started
considering and planning No Deal years
ago two years ago it wouldn't be
crashing out it would be a sensible
logical considered option and before I
finish let me just go to the David
Cameron cuz we keep talking about David
Cameron and saying about him calling
there's let's just look at today
recently whether or not he regrets his
decision
do you regret calling the referendum
September mr. Cameron I don't regret
calling the referendum I made a promise
in the election to call a referendum and
I called the referendum obviously I'm
very concerned about what's happening
today but I do support the Prime
Minister in her efforts to try and have
a close partnership with the European
unit it's the right thing to do and she
has my section violet George Osborne who
was then Chancellor warned him against
it so don't do it because you could lose
this and you don't think you're going to
lose this the use of Internet what
happens now there was an interesting
poll in the Economist last week which
said if you had a people's vote again
what would happen and if you had it just
between the remainders and the No Deal
it was 40 percent said they'd vote for
No Deal 50 percent said their vote for
in mine and 10 percent didn't know if
you had it between the remainders and
the government deal it was 46 percent
for Maine and 38 percent for the
government deal so oddly I mean
hanging out is what popular than mrs.
Mays day I think if you had a second
referendum lot of people second
referendum you would need to say
something around the percentages because
if you ended up in a situation where you
had 48 52 yeah but I'm not saying that
should have been perfect I don't want a
second referendum I know but I'm saying
if that's what gets forced through with
a second referendum I think you need to
look at the percentage yeah sure you
vote you doubt if there was another
referendum would you still vote out yeah
I would Nick oh yeah because I've always
said it wasn't necessary the right time
but the principle the European project
has gone in the wrong direction and I'm
the same with you but I don't know
anyone that voted brexit that would
change there but I'm not saying I don't
speak for all break what happened is a
lot of people that didn't vote will vote
no I know people who voted for breaks it
who wrote age but not large enough yes
and I think the polls suggest that
there's anything more than 1% would
change